we've we have an invention now that's
the new thing yes this is uh something
for the first time that we've taught to
think yeah it's like we created
something to think big mistake you think
it is you think we should put Pandora
back in a box a lot of good could come
out of it right a lot of guys
if you [__] they're gonna be able to
make an AI woman like yes [__] the
flashlight try out of curiosity I have
yeah it feels great it's great but
here's how did I know here's well yes I
tried
here's why AI is not good right you keep
saying the sex robot thing right what do
I want at least in a sex robot than
human emotion I don't want a sex drama
going I have a headache or whatever he
defiled me no that's why I got you the
[__] robot and the same with the
women you don't want to go vibrator
being like you're not so fresh you know
that's gonna [__] you up right so I
think this once the sex robots get
emotion we're gonna shut the whole thing
down because some nerd science is going
to be plowing his lady and she's or his
sex robot and she's gonna be like I
didn't ask for this or whatever and he's
gonna go all right this is not good